welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is Eric Trexler I am the
one and only full-time permanent host of
the show and today's episode is going to
be a special one for the first time ever
we are digging into the stronger by
science archives and re-airing an
episode from a prior season now we're
doing that for a very good reason if you
haven't checked your calendar lately
it's already December which means people
are going to be getting ready for a
brand new year and a brand new set of
goals to go with it so what we wanted to
do was use this episode to kind of kick
start a series of episodes and what
we're going to do over the next few
weeks is talk about how to set goals how
to change behaviors and how to put
together a diet that's going to help you
achieve your goals in the new year
so we're going to replay episode 71
which is all about evidence-based
strategies for goal setting so without
further Ado enjoy the show
um all right so now moving on we've got
a really lengthy segment here it's a
research review I suppose
um
but it's a really comprehensive segment
about New Year's resolutions and goal
setting and you might be listening and
say well I don't really have a New
Year's resolution this year so not
interested but I would encourage people
to uh to give it a shot here because
it's a broader uh evidence-based
perspective related to effective goal
set goal setting and behavior change and
so even if you don't have a New Year's
resolution you will probably at some
point have a goal or a health related
behavior that you wish to change or you
might coach people or train people who
have goals and aspirations related to
behavior change so this is one area of
research where
you know Greg we kind of are in a little
bubble of evidence-based Fitness and you
don't see a lot of people venturing into
this topic with a really evidence-driven
approach you know like it's it's kind of
a
a bit ironic but I think in our little
corner of Fitness people with the
physiology go so heavy on like if you
don't have six citations I don't want to
hear what you're saying yeah but then
when it comes to like motivation and
goal setting and behavior change
that it's like there's just no value for
it yeah they I mean
I was gonna say they I know I've been
guilty of this when you start talking
about goal settings just like I learned
about uh smart goals like the acronyms
smart and undergrad when I was 19. yeah
and uh yeah I mean that that seemed
pretty legit so let's let's just roll
with that and uh get through it as
quickly as possible so we can talk about
physiology right yeah and so um what I
wanted to do is actually dig into some
of this research and come out with some
uh really practical applicable tips to
set very good goals that can facilitate
lasting Behavior change and Lasting
habit formation when applicable so the
first thing I mentioned uh
in our previous our most recent podcast
episode was I kind of mocked the uh the
the genre of post that is common in late
December in Fitness which is like listen
if you don't care enough to have started
yesterday don't even try like you're not
serious enough you don't have the
motivation you're doomed if you really
cared you'd start now or yesterday
um and one of the things that the snarky
part of me that I I try to suppress but
often fail was curious about is do we
have a similar level of uh completely
phony urgency in the peer-reviewed
literature
and I did find a paper that I thought
was hilarious it was in the uh the bmj
British medical journal they do like a
Christmas issue where they they kind of
publish like really silly facetious
articles yeah they just let it hang
loose a little bit yeah and so I found
one and at the risk of being completely
trolled I probably should have actually
replicated some of their searches to see
if these numbers are real but it
wouldn't be funny if they were just
making up numbers I I actually believe
that They carried out the methods that
they uh that they claimed to have
carried out but they were kind of poking
fun at the same thing in peer-reviewed
literature which is this like completely
phony fraudulent urgency that's not
actually based on anything uh and based
on their uh based on their paper the
number of
uh titles in the peer-reviewed research
saying that the time to act is now uh
has gone up exponentially since 2009
over the last uh like 10 years or so it
has just absolutely skyrocketed so well
I mean independent of their search where
they're actually like pulling in papers
and whatnot I just ran a PubMed search
on the term the time to act as now and I
mean that looks like a exponential
growth curve for for the for the YouTube
viewers I'm going to put my computer in
front of the camera real quick to to let
to let you see this oh boy
it is a very very large very steep
increase yeah you're good
so yeah basically people have caught on
to this literary device of just saying
like instead of just saying this is
important I'm going to say that you
should have acted yesterday
um
now
what I wanted to do was look at the
actual research uh and say is that true
like the people who are setting these
New Year's resolutions and you know
uh waiting for the new year are they
really setting themselves up for failure
what is the success rate for these
resolutions and uh as an extension of
that what can we do to make resolutions
better maybe it is start three days
earlier but my hypothesis was that
probably wasn't the trick well I mean I
gotta say if like a lot of uh
like a lot of New Year's resolutions are
either related to like health and
fitness or like finances and I mean just
purely based on the types of resolutions
being said because a lot of people do
set those types of resolutions I think
it does kind of make sense to wait until
New Year's because like right you know
if if you're trying to lose weight
you're going to be going to holiday
parties probably assuming you have
family and friends
um and like there's gonna be good stuff
to eat there and so you know is is when
you're first starting out a new goal is
that when you want to invest a lot of
willpower into like you know
sticking to a goal that that you haven't
really had a chance to turn into a habit
yet and same thing with like Financial
based goals like you know you're buying
presents for people you're probably
traveling like after New Year's that
that seems like a good time to to lock
that stuff down so just purely based on
the types of goals people set I think uh
regardless of motivation there are
practical reasons to wait until the new
year oh yeah for sure and the behavior
change literature the goal setting and
goal attainment literature would
reinforce your your intuition like [ __ ]
yeah you if you especially if you have a
poorly designed goal with really
insufficient architecture behind it uh
yeah if you have a poorly designed goal
uh which we'll talk about the
characteristics of a good design a
well-designed goal later but a poorly
designed goal met with initial failures
uh that's an awful recipe for success
and that's why I think a lot of people
um you know yeah a lot of people do wait
uh but you also uh suspected that you
know most New Year's resolutions do tend
to be something Fitness related if you
know and also some Finance involved
there and that is definitely uh
supported by the literature so there's a
study by oscarson and colleagues uh just
a year or two ago
and they they looked at this big group
of people with New Year's resolutions
and the topics by popularity the number
one uh topic by far for New Year's
resolutions was physical health number
two was weight loss those alone account
for over half within their sample which
had hundreds of people uh something
related to eating is the next with with
13 uh so when you look at the first like
five or six categories uh most of them
are Fitness or health related and then
Finance personal finance did was about
two percent of the sample as well so uh
the research does indicate that a lot of
people set New Year's resolutions and
they do often tend to skew toward
Fitness related topics which is actually
great because when you you know I was a
little bit worried when I own a fitness
company and you're planning like when am
I going to run a sale on a product no so
you're saying for like most people so
it's good for us I'm saying
my genuine thing I was trying to say was
when you are looking into Behavior
research one of the things you have to
be concerned about is generalizability
yeah so okay you had them in this
experimental task and you made these
inferences about Behavior change but can
I actually translate that to working out
to dietary adherence one of the really
nice thing is that when people look at
goal related research they say oh let's
find New Year's resolution people and
when they look for those people they're
all doing Fitness stuff so in terms of
generalizability we're actually really
lucky in this field because they are
studying the exact resolutions that we
want to be making inferences about so uh
that is what I was getting at but like I
said a lot of people make New Year's
resolutions there's a 2002 study uh
randomly called a bunch of folks at the
very end of November and of the 434
respondents to their phone survey 41
indicated uh that they that they did
have a New Year's resolution in mind
that would be starting within the next
week or two
um but anyway one of the things I wanted
to look at initially was just this
concept that New Year's resolutions just
don't work because clearly it's not
important enough for you to start now is
that actually supported by evidence the
answer is in my opinion no I mean that
uh
that particular perspective isn't really
specific enough to truly disprove but
when you look at the rates of success in
studies on New Year's resolutions they
actually don't seem that bad at least
from my perspective so there's a study
in 2002 they found that six months into
the year uh 69 of the resolutionaries
that they kept in contact with reported
that they were still successful with
their resolution at the time of contact
so basically are you doing the stuff you
wanted to do right now six months after
into the new year uh and 46 percent of
them uh reported that they maintained a
continuous success so not just that they
were still doing it now but they had
been doing it continuously for the
preceding six months so about half of
people said yeah I'm doing pretty good
and of course that is self-reported but
I think it's nice uh like yourself uh
the way you view your success matters
and is important in the context of
behavior change and goal attainment so
these people in their own mind were
still being successful you know six
months into it there was also that study
by oscarson that I mentioned
uh where the self-reported success rates
after 12 months were around 55 percent
that ain't bad that's pretty good so
yeah what you know you could nitpick
about you know what you consider to be
true success and whether or not their
objective success matches their
subjective experience but without
question about half of these people six
12 months into it feel like yeah I am
doing some nice things to to support my
success in this endeavor so the idea
that these uh resolutions are completely
doomed to fail doesn't seem to be
supported by the literature and like I
said there it's self-reported so that's
a caveat another caveat is that with
surveys
there is some bias that gets introduced
due to lack of follow-up so those
percentages might be skewed a little bit
because you know the people who stop
answering the calls from the researchers
you you could anticipate that a large
percentage of them are not eager to have
that phone call because they feel like
they have failed to some extent in their
uh pursuit of that goal so I wouldn't uh
stake my reputation on these numbers as
being truly robust and generalizable but
they do give the indication that there
are plenty of people out here who's six
and 12 months down the line do believe
that they're still doing a pretty nice
job sticking with these resolutions
now I don't I mean I want to be as
objective as possible and stick to the
evidence and there is a tiny bit of
Merit to that argument that it's bad to
wait and you should have started now
um so when we talk about a New Year's
resolution we're talking about a goal
that Embraces something called an a
temporal landmark and a temporal
Landmark is basically just a distinct
event that stands out relative to our
kind of day-to-day life
um and what it does is it kind of marks
a some kind of marker on our calendar
that distinguishes after from before
yeah so a very basic temporal Landmark
is just on Monday I'm going to tighten
things up you know to the start of a new
week yeah start of a new month and then
of course start of a new year is a
really common thing in terms of temporal
landmarks for goal setting and so these
kind of segment our life into these
discrete accounting periods where we
could say oh 2020 not good 2021 very
good you know it helps us kind of
distinguish dates into these little bins
where we can reflect on our progress
reflect on our success
they also create a separation
when we talk about a temporal landmark
in the future we have a subconscious
tendency and research has kind of
verified this to separate out our future
self from our present self and that's
one of the reasons that these temporal
landmarks are so appealing for goal
setting purposes
is because we can kind of trick
ourselves into believing like currently
yeah not doing great but future me
future me is a stand-up guy like he's
reliable he's resilient he's got his
head on his shoulders I know he's gonna
fix this he's gonna turn it around so it
it creates something that is researchers
call the Fresh Start effect so there's
this renewed enthusiasm in this renewed
self-efficacy that future you definitely
has this handled uh so it kind of feeds
into that that common phrase new year
new you uh research would indicate
that's actually kind of a literal thing
that happens in our head when we have
these temporal landmarks and that can be
a really nice thing so the fresh start
effect is something that we can leverage
in proper goal setting and successful
goal attainment but there is a drawback
that I think gives just the slightest
bit of credibility to that idea that
putting off the start date to later
could have drawbacks and so one of the
things that can one of the the drawbacks
is that we can anticipate this temporal
Landmark uh and there's a study by coup
at all that that looked into this but we
anticipate this future landmark and we
separate future self from current self
uh and while that can increase
self-efficacy and we can say yeah future
me definitely has this covered it can
also lead to this kind of optimistic
belief that like the things I'm doing
now are truly not my problem like future
me is gonna have to sort through this
that's up to them I'm sure they can
handle it but what we can see is that
there can be a slight reduction in
motivation to persist right now or to do
things that feed into that goal right
now because you're like whatever dude
future me is going to to take care of it
now that is the kind of evidence-based
slight bit of credibility that that
leads into that perspective but as you
alluded to previously I think the
Practical circumstances kind of outweigh
the this potential drawback I think when
you weigh the pros and cons of starting
December 24th it probably does make
sense in totality in my opinion to wait
or at least not to force the issue
because the last thing you want to do is
start out with some big failures and
some big uh you know glaring instances
in which you really fell short of what
you're intending to do with your goals
so um there we do want to be mindful
of this idea of kind of Shifting
responsibility to a future self we don't
want to be sabotaging our future self
because we are letting go of that
responsibility but for practical reasons
uh I I do think that sometimes it makes
sense to leverage temporal landmarks and
to capitalize on the renewed enthusiasm
and to capitalize on that Fresh Start
effect
however
it is extremely clear looking at the
research uh
Simply Having that Fresh Start effect
just having a temporal Landmark is not
independently sufficient to Spur lasting
Behavior change you know if it really
were that simple then the success rates
for New Year's resolutions would be 80
and above you know we clearly need to do
more to support a successful goal or a
successful New Year's resolution we
can't just trust uh this idea that
future me is just going to take care of
it without any resources or planning so
one of the questions that comes up you
mentioned this previously should we set
a smart goal that's usually where people
start this conversation
um
and I think the first question with a
smart goal is what is it
and the answer is not as straightforward
as a lot of people think uh if you've I
mean I remember even we've talked about
this on the podcast before right we have
there's like a business management thing
yeah so smart goals were created by our
corporate overlords to extract value
from us that is explicitly what they are
for
um and and so like you might look
through the acronym and be like why
would relevant be part of it uh or or
another
um another one is why would achievable
be part of it like shouldn't that be
fairly intuitive
um and so achievable I believe at the
first use was actually just assignable
so it was for like managers to say Okay
can this actually be assigned to someone
on my team that I manage yeah and
relevant I believe I'm not certain about
this but I believe it's first use might
have actually been resourced like are
you providing the resources to your team
to make this happen but anyway if you've
ever looked at the Smart acronyms
floating around down in the fitness
space and been like man
that seems forced well yeah I mean the
the one that I've seen most often in the
fitness space the A and the r are
attainable and realistic yeah it's like
rather that's the same thing right like
so someone's done something to This
Acronym kind of trying to squeeze that
square peg into a round hole Yeah so if
it feels forced it absolutely is it's
adapted from management stuff uh and
kind of been repurposed in in the
context of health behavior it's not to
say that there's nothing beneficial that
can be drawn from some of these Concepts
but there was a study the one by
oscarson that I mentioned which actually
seemed to
hint at the idea that smart goals
weren't particularly conducive to
sustained health behavior success when
it comes to goals you could make a very
uh defensible interpretation of that
study to suggest to suggest that adding
a smart goal to the mix explicitly using
that criteria for goal setting actually
was a little bit more counterproductive
than productive and it's very possible
that that's because smart goals uh they
seem to focus in many cases a lot more
on uh outcome rather than than process
and they seem to be more discreet rather
than continuous in nature uh so I think
that smart goals uh just leaning on that
acronym is not going to get it done yeah
so looking through the evidence
um
there are quite a few things we can do
to support our success and the first
thing that I came across
um that I think is a really solid
strategy is establishing a goal
hierarchy okay so it's not just setting
a single smart goal and saying yes
that's perfect maybe even a pyramid if
you will the lawyers say we can't use
that term I'm sick of getting letters
from Eric Helms his threats are empty
but still uh but establishing a goal
hierarchy what we're talking about here
is having superordinate goals
intermediate goals and subordinate goals
that all kind of work together so the
subordinate goals support the
intermediate goals which all support the
superordinate goal so the superordinate
goal is at the top of the hierarchy
and it is honestly the type of goal that
people would tell you not to set because
it is so vague so like a superordinate
goal might be I want to improve my
physical health or improve my health
overall and so a lot of times the
conventional wisdom would be like dude
that's so vague has to be useless as a
goal but what it does is you know these
superordinate goals are more like values
you know they are identity based and
they form a really nice
um Foundation they kind of anchor us and
they provide the why to why we're
pursuing a goal so uh if you have a
bunch of these hyper-specific really uh
tiny goals and there's no organizing
structure about why they matter
collectively when we start to lose a
little bit of motivation or lose a
little bit of self-efficacy we don't
have that Foundation to lean on to
remind us why we ought to be sticking
with these things
intermediate goals are a little bit
lower on the hierarchy they're a little
bit less abstract more specific and they
are things that provide General
directions that lean into this the
superordinate goal so if your
superordinate goal is being healthy
which is an example by uh that was used
in a paper by Hockley and colleagues
which I'll certainly uh Link in the show
notes if the superordinate goal is to be
healthy
you might have intermediate goals like
be in good physical shape get enough
sleep avoid stress eat a healthy diet
these are a little bit less vague and
they give us clear routes to accomplish
the superordinate goal and then the
subordinate goals are at the lowest
level of the hierarchy but it doesn't
mean that the least important in fact
these are the goals that we really
interact with on a day-to-day basis and
really form the foundation of the actual
implementation of this Behavior change
so these are the things where something
similar to a Smart goal would actually
make sense you want to give yourself uh
an idea of exactly what you're going to
do and exactly how and when you're going
to do it in order to achieve those
intermediate goals so if your
intermediate goal is to exercise more a
subordinate goal might be a specific
plan to do 45 minutes of resistance
training before work on Mondays
Wednesdays and Fridays at the gym that
is near your office right so now we're
getting into more of the conventional
concept of what a good goal looks like
um so normally the advice with goal
setting is to keep your goals small and
manageable and restricted to a really
specific action and that's partially
good advice it's great advice for a
subordinate goal but if you just have a
bunch of miscellaneous subordinate goals
and there's really no hierarchy that
gives them architecture and ties them
together those subordinate goals can be
really hard to stick with
and what's really important about these
superordinate goals like I said they
they give us a foundation
that really promotes success so their
their identity based which means that
they they enhance the meaning of all the
goals that come lower on the hierarchy
and and they really heighten the
importance of what we're trying to do
right so when we start to set these
subordinate goals they seem a little bit
arbitrary because they're so specific
but when you have a good superordinate
goal in mind and your motivation starts
to wane a little bit because they're
identity based it really makes you
wrestle with the question is the type of
person I'm trying to become the type of
person who falls short of these little
things that previously seemed really
miscellaneous and kind of scattered and
not not really cohesively feeding into a
bigger picture yeah you know so it
really helps to strengthen our guidance
and enhance the meaning of some of these
goals and it increases our ability to be
flexible you know we might find that
some of our support coordinate goals
aren't really serving the purpose we
hope that they would and we can make
adjustments to those subordinate goals
while maintaining the same general
direction and so that doesn't feel like
a failure it doesn't feel like ah I've
abandoned my goals because I'm not good
enough to do them it's okay this
subordinate goal within this entire mix
of this hierarchy simply wasn't the most
effective way to feed into the higher
levels of the hierarchy yeah so it's a
planned adjustment now it's being
adaptable and flexible it's not simply
succeeding or failing so having this
hierarchy is really helpful for those
purposes and like I said I'm linking the
the full text by Hockley and colleagues
it goes into a lot of detail about the
multi-faceted benefits of superordinate
goals which I think are way too
frequently discounted and undervalued
but another nice thing about having
this hierarchy is it introduces two
concepts one is equifinality and the
other is multi-finality
so equifinality means you can can I just
add something real quick yes so I think
that I think that one of the benefits of
um
what what Hockley is referring to is
superordinate goals is I think that
um
it seems like they largely relate to
Concepts or ideas like self-concept and
I think that if you can leverage that it
helps you kind of like
um leverage cognitive dissonance to your
own benefit because like for example if
you're
um like if if a fundamental part of your
self-concept is like you know like I'm a
lifter I'm someone who takes training
seriously blah blah blah
um one of the
one of like the bits of internal
conflict that you can find people online
working out
publicly is like you know like I'm the
type of person who works out and like
there's this thing coming up which you
know most of the world would view as
like in unalloid good but it is causing
me a sense of stress for example
um you know I'm getting married and I'm
going on my honeymoon for two weeks and
like the place we're going like the
hotel doesn't have a gym it's like what
am I gonna do
um and like is it I'm not saying that
that's a particularly good thing but uh
I I think kind of the idea underpinning
that is like you know this is such a
core piece of who I am that being unable
to do it
um kind of causes some degree of
cognitive dissonance like how can I be
the type of person who works out as like
a core part of who I am and then like
not be able to do it for a semi-extended
period of time and then you can see
um like lifters dealing with a
significant injury kind of like
processing the same thing and so you
know I
I I don't know that that's always
necessarily a good thing but like it's a
Wellspring of internal motivation to
keep doing this thing because like not
doing it feels like a pretty big a
pretty big conflict with who you are
like your entire concept of yourself
um and so you know if you if you view
yourself as a a not exercising type
individual and you want to start
exercising then you know if if there's a
week or two where you don't exercise at
all there's going to be kind of less
mental friction there because it's not
really conflicting with how you view
yourself but in in pursuit of a
superordinate goal if you can like over
time change your self-concept then it
becomes both easier to do the things
that you're wanting to do and if
anything over time it can become
challenging to not do those things yeah
like not engage in those be behaviors
that that you're trying to
newly Implement if that makes sense
absolutely yeah one of the kind of main
points or one of the the really big
points that they highlight when they
talk about the value of superordinate
goals is what they call strengthened
guidance and the way they put it is um
that focusing on superordinate goals not
only increases performance but can also
guide the choice of identity congruent
actions so it's exactly what you're
talking about there with hell yeah it
becomes so identity based and you want
to have that congruency is it congruence
congruency whatever uh between what I'm
doing and this idea of self that I have
in mind related to my goal and another
thing that is really valuable here
something that they also bring up is the
topic of
sustained discrepancy so over the long
term uh having this whole hierarchy of
goals including a superordinate goal
it reinforces this sustained discrepancy
between the status quo where you're at
now what you're doing now and the
desired end point so it's always there
to have this kind of motivating driving
force of this is the aspiration in in
the big picture and there is still a bit
of a discrepancy between where I am now
and where I want to be and that can be
something that fuels motivation and
enthusiasm without feeling like failure
you know it's this kind of aspirational
look at a big picture goal so absolutely
you are right on the money
and where where I left off here was the
two last points of having this hierarchy
you know the the really big upsides here
equifenality and multi-finality so
equifinality means that a goal can be
supported by multiple distinct goals
that are lower on the hierarchy
um and so for example uh being healthier
you can support that through eating
better sleeping better better Stress
Management things like that so when your
motivation to exercise is low you can
still stay on track with your
superordinate goal because you can shift
a little bit more Focus to your dietary
habits or some other aspect feeding into
that higher goal so it provides an
element of flexibility that can help
reinforce your long-term goal attainment
you know you don't always have to be
perfect with every aspect when you have
equifinality there are multiple ways for
you to do something today a that feeds
into the higher levels of what you're
trying to pursue now multi-finality is a
little bit different it means that a
single goal can support multiple
different goals that are higher on the
hierarchy so an example that I came up
with for this is like going for an
outdoor jog you know so of course that
would support perhaps an intermediate
goal of getting more physical activity
but it could also favorably impact your
sleep habits which we we talked about
earlier and maybe if you're doing this
jog in the morning
it forces you to have a consistent wake
up time so it's it's you know
reinforcing good wake and sleep patterns
while also giving you better sleep
quality through exercise so that outdoor
jog is not just more physical activity
it relates to you know getting better
sleep which feeds into Health it can
also relate to we've talked about this
on the show before but going from really
sedentary to fairly active can recouple
your satiety signals so that your
appetite is better regulated relative to
your energy expenditure so that jog is
actually influencing several
intermediate goals that still feed into
the superordinate goal so you can see
that there's tremendous value in this
flexibility because even if you're at a
point where you say honestly dude I
don't really give a [ __ ] about
cardiovascular fitness today I'm kind of
over it you might feel tempted to skip
that run that is kind of built into your
your subordinate goal but then you think
well
I do sleep so much better when I run and
it does help curb my appetite a little
bit so for those other reasons you're
still able to kind of find that
motivation to feed into that behavior
yeah so there's a lot of benefit from
having a rich robust hierarchy of goals
that capitalize on equifenality and
multi-finality and ultimately feed into
something that is identity based yeah
and I think um
like just just kind of Stew it on this a
little bit while you were talking
something that occurs to me as well is
that
I think having I think setting a
superordinate goal necessarily requires
a bit of additional reflection
um because like it's ultimately about
like like what do I want to be who am I
trying to become uh and I think that
that often
um kind of like helps you drill down
into kind of what whatever the the
proximate goal you had for yourself is
it it makes you ask yourself like why do
I want this
um and I think that's relevant uh in the
context of a lot of people setting New
Year's resolutions around weight loss
because
you know if if you stop and think about
it for a second uh if if you were to ask
someone like why do you want to lose
weight generally it's not for its own
sake you know
um generally I mean generally people
either want to lose weight to get
healthier or to uh like be more
conventionally attractive like I I think
those are like 90 of the reasons that
people want to lose weight like
generally people aren't just trying to
be skinny for its own sake with no other
yeah
behind it yeah we get a lot of
applications for coaching and say yeah
I'd like to lose this many pounds
because you know I'm on The Dating
market and I feel more confident yeah
yeah uh and so like you know those are
the things people are trying to get out
of it so they're setting the goal of
like I want to lose weight but then the
question is like why like what is that
going to get you
um and like ultimately what type of
person is that leading you towards being
and so you know if if the underlying
motivation is I want to be healthier
then like you were saying that can that
can be the source of a lot of other
super or uh subordinate goals where you
know like maybe losing weight is going
to be good for you maybe eating better
is going to be good for you like there's
there's a lot of ways to become
healthier
um
and I mean you know a lot of people
struggle with weight loss and if there's
six subordinate goals you set for
yourself and maybe weight loss is still
a challenge but you make meaningful
progress on four of the six like
ultimately you are getting closer like
you're making progress towards the
actual thing you care about that was
motivating the weight loss in the first
place
um and same thing like you know if
you're mostly trying to lose weight to
like feel more confident
um be more uh conventionally attractive
with however you define that term like
you know there's a lot of other ways you
can go about doing that like you can
improve your uh personal grooming you
can work on trying to become funnier uh
you can pick up more hobbies that people
will find interesting like you know
there's there's a lot of roads that lead
to Rome and I think
by trying to set a superordinate goal it
kind of forces you to interrogate kind
of the initial subordinate goal you were
trying to set for yourself
um to to basically find for yourself
more paths to success yeah you know I'm
glad that you brought up uh weight loss
as the example because
um it's the perfect example of when
failing to have a rich goal hierarchy
sets you up for failure because you know
you think of weight loss generally
speaking as you were alluding to that's
somewhere in the intermediate to
subordinate range of goals
um and usually intermediate uh you know
usually there are tasks you do to
facilitate weight loss which feeds into
a superordinate goal ideally but if all
you do is focus on an intermediate goal
I mean that's clearly not a good
strategy right because you're not
setting up enough
you're not setting up enough
specific subordinate goals to actually
feed into it and you don't have the
actual anchor of the superordinate goal
to reinforce why we're even doing this
in the first place so this it's just
this singular intermediate goal floating
out here with no foundation with no
support and yeah it's not a good
strategy
and what you're getting at there uh this
idea of
the superordinate goal
challenging us to wrestle with this and
figure out what are the paths to the
goal that actually matters to me that
hits on a topic that I actually had
later in the outline which is the topic
of mental contrasting and so with mental
contrasting what you do is you envision
a desired future which generally entails
you successfully achieving your goal and
then you contrast it with the present
reality and when you do that it
encourages you to wrestle with that
contrast the differences between this
idealized future and the present reality
and that can spur action and you know
introduce a higher level of enthusiasm
but it also causes you to uh and there
is research indicating that it increases
expectations of success which feeds into
self-efficacy which is very very
positive but it causes you to identify
specific obstacles and that really is
the key to setting up one of these these
hierarchies is you need to identify
those specific obstacles and your
intermediate and subordinate goals
should be targeting those specific
obstacles so absolutely having a
superordinate goal pushes kind of nudges
us toward this mental contrasting which
helps us fill in this hierarchy but
without question that the process of
goal setting
needs to be extremely reflective and
extremely well thought out and so like
you said it can't be as simple as just
weight loss it's got to be weight loss
for what and why and also how and when
you put it in that framework uh good
luck writing a smart goal that that
covers all that right it's just it's
it's not an intuitive way to make it
work uh the last thing I want to mention
here though if I could take a slight
detour on the road to Enlightenment
revive the segment one of the concepts
that comes up a lot in uh you know
Buddhist teachings is recognizing that
you do have the resources that you
require to to become what you wish to
become so when we talk about this future
self and current self this idealized
self and the present self I don't want
people to internalize that as the
current need isn't good enough you know
so that's something that is intuitively
a road we can go down and I don't think
that that's a particularly constructive
Road
for self-efficacy and long-term success
so when we talk about these future
self-current self things and the
difference between them I just want to
reinforce it it doesn't mean that you're
currently not good enough what it means
is that you have the capability within
you it just needs to be accessed it just
needs to be tapped into and that's what
goal setting is about
so if you're setting these things up and
you're continuously kind of
psychologically reinforcing the idea
that current you is not good enough
first of all that sucks that's bad vibes
but second of all that's actually
deleterious to the process of successful
goal attainment so I'm being a little
careless with the the verbiage and the
terminology there and kind of reflecting
some of these individual papers but it's
really important to get out of that trap
of reinforcing the idea that you are not
good enough and not capable you know
it's there it's just about doing proper
goal design so that you can set yourself
up for Success so you can really access
that potential now I do want to briefly
talk about I've been going on for a
while here I do want to briefly talk
about a few other miscellaneous
characteristics of effective goals so I
think by far the most important thing to
to Really sink your teeth into is the
idea of a robust goal hierarchy with
equifinality and multi-finality but
there are a number of sub topics that
are really important so the first one I
want to talk about is approach versus
avoidance uh very very important uh and
it's a fairly simple distinction
um
if you wish to uh improve the quality of
your diet right if that's your goal
um an approach goal would be something
like eating more vegetables or eating
more protein right uh in contrast an
avoidance goal that is more diet
oriented might be uh eating dessert less
frequency or consuming fewer sugar
sweetened beverages right so an approach
focused goal is what are the things I'm
seeking out here what are the things
that I'm adding into my life and and
approaching avoidance is what is the
stuff I'm going to cut out of my life
the things that I like but I'm going to
force myself to avoid and there's
absolutely evidence indicating that
approach focused goals they inherently
frame these changes in a more positive
light which is a good thing and they
have been associated with more positive
emotions more positive thoughts better
self-evaluations and greater overall
psychological well-being but I that
makes sense because with uh with
avoidance oriented goals
you know you're you're trying to not do
something you're currently doing and
generally you're only currently doing
something either because you like to do
it or it's just like the convenient
thing to do it's an ingrained habit yeah
yeah so
um like a approach oriented goal could
be easy could be hard
you never know but like in avoidance
oriented goal I think is almost
necessarily an uphill battle yep because
you're you're either telling yourself
I'm not going to do this thing that I
like to do or
um like I'm going to try to give up
doing this thing that even if I don't
particularly like it it's very habitual
it's very ingrained so like yeah you're
you're necessarily attempting to fight
against the current whereas with with
approach oriented goals you know
especially if you're the type of person
who likes novelty likes likes doing new
things it may just be easy and fun to do
or you know it could be challenging but
there's you know there's a spectrum
there whereas I feel like the vast
majority of approach oriented goals are
going to be challenging and fairly
unpleasant yeah in the psychological
ramifications I think are also really
intuitive because you've identified this
avoidance goal it's this thing about you
and the way you behave that you think is
bad right and so it's kind of
automatically reinforcing that idea of
like dude I suck but maybe someday I
won't suck you know like which is not a
good starting point for self-efficacy
and positive psychological outcomes
um and if if that isn't enough to
convince you just based on the
subjective experience that you know
approach oriented goals are more
enjoyable and more positive uh the study
by oscarson that I keep mentioning from
2020 uh in people who mostly had Fitness
oriented New Year's resolutions they
were significantly more successful if
they took an approach oriented goal
setting strategy rather than an
avoidance oriented strategy so there is
empirical evidence that it is simply a
more successful route to take aside from
just being a much better vibe to follow
as the first and only Fitness podcast
with a steadfast commitment to
traditional Family Values we know that
protecting families is important right
you are Eric but I will note there are
some things that are even more important
than protecting traditional family
values and the moral fabric of our
society that's right Greg it's important
to protect families but it's even more
important to protect corporate entities
that's why I joined the Advisory board
for the Sports Nutrition Association
Along with trusted Fitness Pros like
Danny Lennon and distrusted arch nemesis
like Eric Helms the Sports Nutrition
Association is the home of Sports
Nutrition they are dedicated to ensuring
the sustainable prosperity of the Sports
Nutrition profession and they offer a
unique Pathway to robust insurance
coverage for your Sports Nutrition
business simply put it's the best way to
protect the corporate entities that are
closest to your heart and I should note
if you're an individual soul rioter
providing Sports nutrition services and
not a corporate entity the Sports
Nutrition Association can help you out
as well that is correct all insurance
plans are handled individually on a
case-by-case basis regardless of how
your Sports Nutrition business is
structured but even if you don't want
insurance coverage sna membership comes
with a bunch of other perks and
advantages the Sports Nutrition
Association is the only Global
professional sports body that has a
defined standard for Sports Nutrition
scope of practice for its members this
ensures that members maintain high
standards in their practice so that the
public can always trust in the quality
associated with the services of an
accredited Sports nutritionist through
the Sports Nutrition Association if you
already meet their minimum education
requirements you can become an
accredited Sports nutritionist today if
you don't meet those education
requirements yet you can enroll in the
certificate program in a applied Sports
Nutrition that allows you to become a
provisionally accredited member upon
completion to learn more about the
Sports Nutrition Association head over
to
www.sportsnutritionassociation.com today
today's episode is sponsored by the
Sports Nutrition Association and
stronger by science LLC sincerely
appreciates their support
now another topic I want to talk about
another kind of dichotomy here
flexible restraint versus rigid
restraint this is something that comes
up a lot in nutrition
um and and I think it's very poorly
understood absolutely yeah and the
reason I say that is because until maybe
like three years ago I thought I
understood this concept and I [ __ ]
didn't uh Eric Helms had a good I think
video series for Mass uh talking about
approach or talking about uh rigid
versus flexible restraint in the cons in
the context of dieting like flexible
dieting and like I thought I knew what
that was and then I watched his videos I
was like oh I was wrong yeah yeah so
just to to provide some context here so
someone who applies rigid restraint to
their diet is going to tend to set a lot
of inflexible rules and boundaries uh
they're often going to evaluate their
adherence in dichotomous terms so they
had a good day of dieting or an
unsuccessful day right pass or fail good
or bad there's no gray area where it's
like yeah I was only 60 calories over
that's fine uh so rigid dichotomies
rigid rules and boundaries often they'll
restrict themselves to a really small
list of diet approved foods or they'll
aim to hit their daily macro targets or
their calorie targets with a completely
impractical level of precision and they
will aim for Perfection at the expense
of flexibility adaptability and
practicality and when they do fall short
of perfection it's internalized as a
categorical failure now in contrast
someone with flexible restraint with
their diet is going to be the opposite
of that it's it's more pragmatic it's
more flexible there are goals sometimes
there will be small deviation sometimes
there will be large deviations from
those different targets but someone who
is close to hitting their target can say
hey
pretty close not bad you know uh so what
you were getting at
is the fact that there are a lot of
people
who do flexible dieting yeah I think if
you ask most people like most Fitness
people on Instagram what is flexible
dieting they'll probably be like ah you
can eat whatever Foods you want as long
as you're within five grams of every
macro right and like yeah yeah I
actually feel pretty rigid I would love
to see some survey research figuring out
of the percentage of what percentage of
people doing flexible dieting are
actually exercising rigid restraint uh
and coming from the bodybuilding and
physique world my gut reaction is 99.
but of course I understand it's a skewed
perspective right yeah but but there are
so many people who are like dude
flexible dieting is great it gave me a
new lease on life and it's like yeah but
your goal for fat intake is 65 and if
you have 67 it you you view that as like
a categorical failure I'm not sure
that's flexible well I mean I I guess
it's a
I guess it's a matter of degree right
yeah like you know you can't just
strictly categorize things as flexible
or rigid like yeah a lot of people who
are doing really a quite rigid form of
what they call flexible dieting it very
well could be a dietary approach that is
that get that does give them far more uh
flexibility than whatever they were
doing previously yeah but in the grand
scheme of things it's it's still fairly
rigid right yeah it's definitely a
spectrum and you can go from extremely
rigid to pretty rigid and that could be
a huge impact on quality of life and the
practicality and the pragmatic value of
what you're doing nutritionally that's
definitely a good point
um but now that we've kind of set up
these terms you will be very unsurprised
to learn that that research has shown
that uh rigid restraint with dieting
tends to be associated with disordered
eating symptoms uh body image concerns
poorer well-being and just a wide range
of negative psychological outcomes and
it's not just it hasn't only been
studied in the context of nutrition I
actually came across a study looking at
smoking cessation and what they found
was that trying to implement flexible
restraint to just lower the amount of
smoking like the number of cigarettes
that people were smoking in different
experimental contexts the flexible
restraint uh approaches were actually
more successful than the rigid restraint
approaches when it came to just getting
people to smoke less within different
contexts so uh definitely whenever
possible flexible restraint
is going to be uh really advisable now
there are going to be some I should
acknowledge there are going to be some
habits and behaviors that are really
really deleterious that you might say
honestly doing this one time a week is
truly one too many like like there are
going to be contexts where that is the
case
um but for most contexts you can find a
way to work flexible restraint rather
than rigid uh another one here uh
process versus outcome
uh there was uh a paper by Captain and
freund no way I'm pronouncing that
correctly but that's fine
um but the paper was called the way is
the goal
the role of go folk goal focus for
successful goal Pursuit and subjective
well-being
um
the thing I liked about this is they
actually the title is kind of a play on
words the way is the goal
um it's extremely similar to a literary
uh device that I've seen used by uh Tik
not Han who's a really well-known uh
Buddhist teacher and he always talks
about like there is no way to happiness
happiness is the way which is focus on
the process of being happy now don't
focus on what's going to lead you to
happy outcomes some arbitrary future
date yeah uh and that's exactly what
they were getting at I I think that's
also God any any like history of
philosophy people listening are about to
be very mad but that was something that
either Plato or Aristotle said as well I
think it was Plato and it's seems like
more of a Play-Doh thing yeah
um that like ultimately like like
happiness is the chief good it's the
chief goal because like ultimately if
you examine any goal
um and ask like well why do you want
that and then they give an answer well
why do you want that then they give an
answer uh like ultimately it's just like
because I I think if I do this I'll be
happier and then you ask like well why
do you want to be happier
and like there's not a good answer to
that like people just [ __ ] like being
happy like that's that's the whole point
of it so it's kind of like the only goal
that is not
feeding into something else yeah
um so yeah that that sounds like a a
reasonably similar concept yeah uh so in
this paper basically it's a very simple
conclusion they give you I don't know
probably three or four thousand words
worth of it but the general idea is when
you when you look at uh goal Pursuit and
and there's you know these two
contrasting uh focal points focusing on
the process versus focusing on the
outcome uh the Empirical research
supports the idea that focusing more on
the process
um it's more adaptive uh it sets up a
higher level of success it does feed
into greater rates of goal attainment
you know more successful goal attainment
and it also leads to a more positive
subjective experience when people focus
more on the process than the goal they
in enjoy the goal striving process to a
higher degree and they also as a nice
added bonus happened to be a little bit
more successful in actually achieving
some of those endpoints that are
important to them so whenever possible
it certainly seems that adopting a more
process focused approach to goal
achievement or goal Pursuit
seems to be the better option so
focusing on what can I do today what can
I do now what are the aspects of this
process that I can engage with day to
day because
you know something that comes up is the
fact that we typically spend well we
almost always spend way longer pursuing
our goals than experiencing the
attainment of our goals that was a thing
that they highlighted in the paper and
it reminds me of something that my
football coach used to say all great
wisdom comes from a high school football
coach we can agree there's you know
Plato and Aristotle and your high school
defensive ends coach yeah but uh anyway
he said you know people were being
dragging our feet around practice oh
this sucks he was like listen you better
start liking practice because we have 10
games and we have like a thousand
practices so like this sport is way more
practicing than it is playing the games
yeah and it's the same kind of idea with
Goal Pursuit it's like you better get to
liking the active pursuit of your goal
because you're going to spend a lot more
time on that than the one day where you
finally check off the box and say Yes
goal has been detained yes so it's a
similar concept of focusing on the
process more so than the outcome and
ironically when you do that you're
probably more likely to actually reach
that outcome eventually yeah now the
next one Mastery versus performance
um
with a Mastery goal you could also call
it a learning goal what you're trying to
do is learn new skills
attain new abilities you're trying to
master a new thing
um and so the opposite of that would be
a performance goal which is purely just
you know focused on you know did I
perform up to expectation based on the
goal that I set so performance goals uh
just kind of you know pass failed did I
do a good job on this uh the downside
there is that if you fail to achieve uh
a performance goal you're probably going
to interpret that as a really negative
thing a failure uh an insufficient
ability to get the job done and we don't
internalize that well and that does not
feed into high levels of self-efficacy
or confidence or enthusiasm about
continued goal Pursuit now when we have
a goal that focuses on Mastery it's in
many cases there's going to be something
like learning a new skill and so when we
run into challenges there and we run
into things where we really aren't doing
a good job with it at all think of the
last time you tried to learn something
truly new
you don't internalize that as like oh
man I'm just a worthless person what you
say is damn this is hard
I knew it was going to be hard maybe I
need to reassess the way I'm approaching
it maybe I need to try some new
strategies to master this task when you
can find a way to make your goals
focused on Mastery rather than
performance it's not always going to be
feasible to do that depending on your
goal but it builds in a level of
flexibility it builds in problem solving
active engagement with getting through
the challenges because the the
challenges are expected to be part of it
right so it can be a really positive
thing that increases your self-efficacy
when you're pushing yourself to do new
things you will run into friction and
challenges but you can push through
those and be adaptable and be creative
and it's even more fulfilling in many
cases when you're able to learn a new
thing and look back and say I'm maybe
I'm only 40 percent of my way to the
real end point that I had in mind with
some of my higher level goals but look
at this progress dude like I used to be
so bad at cooking and look at how many
new dishes I can cook and so like you
know a good idea a good um example with
Mastery like a performance goal might be
lose 10 pounds and then you you wake up
one day and wait is about two pounds
higher than you expect and you're like
dude this sucks I failed right but with
Mastery you could say I want to get
better at cooking I want to learn how to
track my nutrition more effectively uh I
want to learn a new type of physical
activity so that I can promote energy
expenditure you know like uh this
upcoming year I'm going to get into
paddle boarding which I'm really excited
about that is going to increase my
cardio respiratory Fitness but it's also
just going to be a fun new thing to to
work on you know so trying to
incorporate Mastery is a really positive
thing so something that occurs to me
about that as well is
um
so a lot of a lot of outcomes you want
to achieve I think a lot of the skills
necessary to bring about those outcomes
like oftentimes there's a process where
you have to accumulate enough skill for
like you know underlying components that
are going to contribute to the outcome
before you actually start noticing
meaningful impacts on the outcome so uh
like the the paddle boarding example you
gave I think is is great like that will
probably improve your cardio respiratory
Fitness once you get pretty good at
paddle boarding but like when you suck
at paddle boarding you probably aren't
going to be able to put enough exertion
into it to stress your cardio
respiratory system enough for there to
be any meaningful aerobic adaptation so
like you need to Matt like you need to
attain a high enough Mastery of paddle
boarding before it can actually
contribute to those other outcomes
you're interested in what what I was
thinking about while you were talking is
um so my love of playing basketball is
is not a secret on this podcast
um so I hit I hit my growth spurt
extremely young like I I essentially
haven't grown since sixth grade and so
between 8th and Ninth Grade I had to
transition from Center to uh shooting
guard point guard because you know I
used to be the tallest guy and then I
very much was not anymore
um so that drop step on the Block was
not quite as valuable as it used to be
correct so like I was a poor dribbler
and I was a poor shooter and you know uh
I you know when you go from being very
bad at dribbling to like kind of bad at
dribbling guess what you're still a
shitty point guard like that does not
improve your point guard play to any
meaningful degree yeah but like you know
I could tell that I was getting better
and then eventually I reached the point
that I did have a good enough handle to
be effective on the court and like same
thing with shooting like if you go from
being a very bad mid-range to outside
shooter to a sort of bad mid-range to
outside shooter that adds virtually no
value to your team because more often
than not unless a possession completely
breaks down there's probably a better
shot on the court and you shouldn't be
taking you know one of those shots
you're not good at but then you
eventually do get good enough that
taking that shot is valuable for your
team so yeah you know there there's a
process where like oftentimes you do
have to accumulate enough underlying
skill for it to actually be useful for
the outcome that you're interested in so
yeah if you go into a just focused on
the outcome there's there's going to be
a very long period of frustration where
it seems like you're not making any
progress towards your goal because your
goal is the outcome yeah but if if
you're more focused on the process and
accumulating that skill even before you
start seeing like a noticeable change in
sort of the outcome you're interested in
you are staying engaged in the process
because you're you're seeing
improvements that you care about along
the way yeah and there's considerable
overlap when we talk about these
different aspects of a good goal uh you
know so like you said Mastery does kind
of force you to be a little bit more
process oriented rather than outcome
oriented especially in the short in the
short term
um and what's really nice about these
Mastery goals is you probably want to
complement them with things that you're
already quite good at when you have when
you look at your entire list of
subordinate goals you want to have some
things that are still moving the needle
related to the outcome because like you
said there could be some lag time there
but what's really nice is with these
Mastery goals you stay engaged on the
process on the process almost by
definition you know they kind of force
you to
and then you achieve them you know and
what's really nice is when you master a
new skill it has a huge boost for your
self-efficacy related to your goal uh
you are now seeing yourself as a person
who achieves things uh and you have a
new relevant skill so you're more
equipped than ever to make big strides
towards some of the higher level goals
so there are a lot of benefits of
incorporating some Mastery focused goals
for sure
now one thing you've mentioned
previously is the idea of goal
difficulty and I'm not going to get
super into the details here but I am
going to link a study by Sharif and Shu
that looks into a concept that I think
is really valuable what they were
looking at is you know there's plenty of
research before their work about how
hard should a goal be and it's fairly
straightforward if it's too easy it's
boring if it's too hard it's
demotivating and discouraging you need
to find a sweet spot it has to be
something that's hard enough to kind of
get your juices flowing but easy enough
that you can make some degree of
satisfactory progress to uh to continue
fueling the effort what they uh looked
into what they uh really came away with
from their study was this idea of
something called slack with a cost
another phrase they use is the emergency
reserve and what they did is they they
had this task the details aren't
critically important but basically there
is an easy goal there is a hard goal
the easy goal is hey do this thing five
days a week the hard goal is hey do this
thing seven days a week there was
another goal that was like Hey do it
five days a week that's your goal and
that's what you get rewarded for in
terms of success and failure but go
ahead and try to do it all seven days
anyway
so there wasn't really a lot of
additional benefit from those extra two
days it was just like you're on the hook
for five days a week but just do the
seven anyway now the final group had
slack with a cost
what that meant was their official goal
was do it all seven days the hard goal
but we will excuse two of them if
necessary so like we will give you some
wiggle room here that is built into your
understanding of the expectations there
was a little cost associated with it if
they used those Reserve days it reduced
their financial compensation but not to
a large degree the real payout was did
you achieve your goal which was
essentially for them five but it was
framed differently it was seven with two
kind of gimmies like two Mulligans what
they found was that that slack with a
cost was uh not not only the most
enjoyable uh like they asked like hey if
you had to do this again which of these
would you prefer they're like yeah give
me the slack with a cost one but also it
led to the highest rates of success in
terms of actually achieving the goal so
there's some value to having this
emergency reserve and one of the uh
examples I saw was
for example they related it to nutrition
and they said like well let's say your
goal for this week is to have a daily
caloric intake of 1900 calories but you
have this emergency Reserve you've got
these like 800 calories that can be
allocated anywhere you want throughout
the week and you don't have to use them
so the goal is you've got 1900 calories
a day plus this emergency reserve of
like 800 extra calories if you want them
and so it's slack because it's like okay
I can like break the glass in case of
emergency and use these 800 calories
have a couple days that are an extra 400
whatever you want to do but what it does
is
um you know there's this slack but like
I said there's a cost right so if you
are repeatedly exhausting the entirety
of that calorie reserved then it will to
a small degree mean okay it might extend
my diet a little bit longer because I am
on average eating a little bit more
throughout the week so that is the idea
of slack with a cost and there is some
empirical evidence to suggest that it's
a really nice way to combine hard goals
that are a bit of a stretch that
incorporate some flexibility some
adaptability and when you lean on that
flexibility it is not internalized as
failure you don't see it as a big hit to
your success or your self-efficacy and
it kind of relates to something we
talked about we did a show about diet
breaks and refeeds and we talked about a
study where there were planned hedonic
deviations that really took the same
form they basically had one day a week
where it's like hey if you want to eat
up to like this many calories just go
for it it's fine and that does seem to
be a really beneficial thing and again
it's it's not
um
it's not a matter of like rigid
restraint where it's like on the diet
for six days and off for the seventh
it's about building in flexibility to
the day-to-day targets
um so when possible slack with a cost is
a really nice way to you sometimes you
can be really nervous about setting a
stretch goal that's really challenging
because you're like well if I keep
failing that's going to be demotivating
building in the slack with a cost allows
us to set these goals that are
challenging enough to be exciting but
feasible enough to be successful so I I
know we've talked about this before I
don't know if we've talked about it on
the podcast or just you and I but
um I had never encountered this idea
before and as you started talking about
this study I was like yeah you know what
that I this is the first thing that
sounds very counter-intuitive doesn't
make sense to me
um like the uh especially the enjoyment
part of it because like comparing the
two conditions of you need to do five
days a week but you can do seven if you
want versus
you need to do seven days a week but
like you can kind of use a bit of a get
out of jail free card to get it down to
five those those functionally seem very
similar but to me if you would have just
described those to me I would have
thought that the you gotta do five but
you can do seven if you want I would
have thought that that would have been
the more the more preferable approach
um because the the goal itself seems
more achievable like it's
easier strictly speaking Yeah but it
does give you the option to go above and
beyond which you know maybe will make
you feel good because like you are uh
exceeding your expectations but both
your expectations for yourself and in
the case of the study the expectations
that the researchers were placing on you
so uh in a vacuum I would have thought
that like oh that's that's definitely
going to be the better approach but then
as you were talking I realized more and
more like oh [ __ ] the the slack with a
cost that's literally how I'm
approaching my diet right now where
um like not currently like I'm
intentionally at maintenance but when
when I'm intending to lose weight I set
my goal for you know the actual rate of
weight loss I want but then I do give
myself that slack where
um you know since since I roughly know
what my maintenance calories are at any
given point in time you know I tell
myself like at least four or five days a
week I do want to be very very very
close to my actual calorie Target for
the day that I've set for myself that's
in line with my goal but then if I need
to go over that like you know if I'm
like if I want to do a bit of stress
eating or if I'm just very hungry for
whatever reason as long as I stay below
whatever that maintenance figure is like
I'm still in good shape like I'm
ultimately I'm still making progress
towards my goal albeit at a somewhat
reduced rate
um which I think sounds identical to
that slack with a cost idea and uh yeah
it's been working really well for me and
uh so
um glad to know that the research
supports it yeah but that that is that
is a novel idea to me yeah and you know
I I agree with you when I first heard
about it I thought that other condition
would be
um
preferable
but I actually have been in that a
scenario like that before and I hated it
uh I was once in a um
a position of employment where
the expectations for me were not made
clear
and it was like one of those things
where at the end of the day you're like
okay boss can I go home now and they're
like well do you feel like you've done
enough
you know it's kind of like uh you know
well I I think I met like the Baseline
expectations like well if if you think
the Baseline expectations are are good
enough then then you would then go
intuitively if you think that's
appropriate you know it's having an
unclear expectations about how hard you
should push for a certain personality
types meet personality type means you
will push to an unreasonable degree or
feel or feel guilty about not pushing I
mean you know what that sounds like to
me what sounds like your boss is trying
to do a bit of wage theft but couldn't
explicitly tell you because then he
could have theoretically gotten in
trouble right yeah but but it's the same
kind of thing where it's like it can be
frustrating because if you don't
actually really indicate that achieving
the goal is achieving the goal then a
person will kind of walk away with a bit
of an empty feeling of like well I did
that easy thing but they did kind of
challenge me to do a harder thing and I
just didn't do it and I don't feel good
about that yeah that that makes a lot of
sense yeah but um yeah so slack with a
cost when possible is a really nice way
to have a challenging goal that gets you
excited but has a little bit of a buffer
in there to keep you on track so when it
comes to setting specific goals
all those characteristics come into play
having a rich hierarchy a very robust
hierarchy of interconnected uh
multi-level goals is a very valuable
thing when you go to set specific goals
you do want to engage with mental
contrasting you want to think okay
there's this positive future where I've
achieved all these goals there's the
current situation where I have not yet
what are the main obstacles there you
identify the obstacles and you start
setting specific goals that are in the
intermediate and subordinate levels but
you want to use something that they call
implementation intentions
this is a very broad concept
generally it's defined as some kind of
if then plan that specifies when where
and how you are going to implement a
behavior leading to the attainment of a
goal so uh you know you might say if
it's a weekday then I will exercise for
at least 45 minutes before work at the
gym nearest my office which is going to
promote my intermediate goal of
exercising more you know so and then
that's going to feed into my
superordinate goal of uh you know
improving my health so what you're
trying to do with implementation
intention is be very specific about your
intentions of how you're going to
implement these different behaviors
leading into goal attainment usually
like I said it's treated like an if then
statement that's kind of the classic
form but there have been some uh
offshoots that have taken different
forms that are still similar in terms of
their premise
um one thing I should mention though is
that there have been really good uh
meta-analyzes multiple meta-analyzes
that I've seen in indicating that this
combination of mental contrasting with
implementation intentions does seem to
be uh does lead to statistically
significant improvements in goal
attainment so this is definitely an
evidence-based combination of strategies
I mentioned some offshoots of
implementation intentions that take a
slightly different form
one is Temptation bundling and I've seen
this I associate it with research by
Katie Milkman I don't know if uh if she
coined the phrase but that's where I
first became aware of it and what you're
doing is kind of pairing a goal directed
behavior that we should do but involve
some kind of delayed gratification
something we know is good for us but in
the short term isn't particularly we
don't love it you're pairing that with
something that's very enjoyable that has
instant gratification but isn't
necessarily goal directed so one of the
studies she did for an example was you
can listen to this really engaging
audiobook that you really like but you
can only do it at the gym
so you go to the gym and do some type of
of aerobic exercise so that you will
have the opportunity to engage with that
thing that you really enjoy and in some
cases it can be a a two-fold benefit
because like if you think of uh let's
say a television show you really like
you might stay home and watch it at the
expense of the gym right so not only are
you not going to the gym but this thing
is kind of pulling you actively away
from the gym you're replacing that habit
or that activity by combining them you
are kind of cutting down on some of that
less productive time that you've spent
and you've also given yourself another
an additional incentive to go in and do
this goal directed Behavior so that's
Temptation bundling and I think that the
nomenclature is a bit counter-intuitive
because to me it sounds like because it
sounds like there's a lot of these
things I want to do that are
counterproductive to my goal and [ __ ] it
I'm going to do it I'm gonna bundle all
of it yeah yeah so it's about bundling a
Temptation with a goal directed Behavior
Uh another thing another kind of
offshoot is the a topic called or a
concept called habit stacking and so
it's first to my knowledge popularized
by BJ Fogg and then double popularized
by James Clear
um but it's uh basically instead of
associating a particular action or
behavior with a time and a place you're
associating it with a different habit
that's already ingrained uh so you might
say I'm going to stretch for five
minutes before I brush my teeth uh or do
a five minute kind of like relaxation
exercise uh before I travel to the gym
so if I'm about to get in the car get on
a bus and go to the gym before I do that
five minute you know relaxation strategy
something like that so you can do it in
the car on the way to the gym just close
your eyes yeah seven seconds in hold for
seven exhale for seven it's great
exactly so and the thing is like if
you're even if you're at highway speeds
you don't cover that much distance When
You Close Your Eyes for 21 seconds like
it's it's actually like kind of crazy
how little you need to look at the road
yeah that's an interesting perspective
um but the benefit here of doing this
type of habit stacking in contrast to
more traditional
um implementation intention is you are
kind of piggybacking on a habit that's
already ingrained like you're gonna
brush your teeth before bed so it's a
good opportunity I'm gonna brush my
teeth before bed it's a good opportunity
to say well that is gonna happen that
habit's already ingrained all I need to
do is tack one little extra wrinkle onto
that and now we've we've got a kind of a
double habit that's forming uh so what
we want to do there like I said uh is
identify these key barriers and then
start talking about specific subordinate
goals we want to be really explicit in
that goal setting process about how
we're going to make those subordinate
goals happen using things like
implementation intentions Temptation
bundling habit stacking a similar other
set of strategies that I won't go into
too much detail about is action planning
and coping planning so action planning
is a similar thing where you you put
together a specific plan about where
when and how a goal is going to be
implemented and then coping plans are
when stuff goes wrong
how am I going to cope with different
challenges that might come up so for
example
a really nice thing I've been enjoying
that's been great for my sleep and wake
Cycles has been enjoying my coffee you
know close to Sunrise over by a lake
that's nearby so action plan is great
wake up coffee's already programmed and
ready to go get out the door get to the
lake enjoy some sunlight some fresh air
the coping strategy is what happens if
it rains well there's a different spot
in this that still is near the lake
that's a covered shelter so if it rains
we've got a backup plan built in so
whatever your specific goal is you want
to identify very likely challenges and
barriers and put together a a proactive
plan so that when those things occur
you're ready to go and you can cope so
there are some additional tools on top
of what we've discussed already that can
be very helpful in facilitating and
supporting goal attainment these are not
necessarily tied into
the goal setting process itself but
something to keep in mind is stimulus
control so non-habit goal directed
behaviors can be impacted by internal
and external stimuli and then habits of
course are heavily heavily impacted by
stimuli so uh you know you drive past a
restaurant that you like and you're kind
of hungry you say you know what that's a
stimulus instead of having the deal the
dinner I was going to cook I'm going to
have that instead uh smelling food
cooking it can sometimes be a cue to eat
even though we're not necessarily hungry
uh eating in response to stress the
emotion is the stimulus that we're
responding to and it might cause us to
deviate from our previous plan uh
something as simple as popcorn at a
movie you might say when I'm at a movie
I eat popcorn even though I don't really
feel like eating popcorn I'm here I'm
gonna do it so what's really important
here is that these different stimuli
whether they're internal like an emotion
or external like smelling food that's
cooking
they can derail some of our planned
behaviors and so what you want to do is
manipulate your environment to the best
of your ability to remove things with a
negative influence to introduce things
with a positive influence and to use
tools when possible to facilitate and to
reinforce positive habit formation you
want to basically make your goal
directed behaviors more resilient and
more robust as it pertains to stimuli
and sometimes it's not about overcoming
the stimuli it's about removing the
stimulus right so for example I noticed
last year when we talked about goal
setting one of the behaviors I had that
or the habits I guess that was really
frustrating was just wasting time in bed
I'd wake up and grab my phone which had
my alarm on it and start looking at
emails and social media I was like dude
I've been in bed for way too long like
this is not okay and so a really easy
you know talking about using tools and
device cases that can help changing the
environment the phone is just gone now I
got like a six dollar alarm clock and it
changed my life the alarm clock goes off
it's not interesting it just tells me
numbers right so the phone is completely
out of the picture and my morning is so
much more productive so these little
things about modifying the environment
are are real can be really impactful
even if it's a simple thing like picking
up a you know a six or seven dollar
alarm clock that that is replacing your
phone for your alarm uh another thing
that you want to think about is social
support and feedback there's plenty of
research indicating that uh using tools
that provide periodic reminders can be
very helpful for staying engaged with a
process related to a goal uh especially
if that periodic feedback or the
periodic reminders are individualized
and frequent
the downside is if they're too frequent
there's Empirical research to indicate
as you would expect people to say dude
leave me alone this is annoying I saw
one study where there was an app related
to nutrition that kept giving this
feedback it was like an average of like
nine pings a week I think and
the regression indicated that over time
people were just like I'm not reading
these anymore so you could see the time
course people were just completely
checking out
um but anyway
feedback reminders that are personalized
individualized frequent can be really
helpful for staying engaged with process
oriented focus and then social support
can be huge having people that support
your goal that can help keep you
accountable uh one of the nice things
one of my goals currently relates to my
morning routine uh my girlfriend
participates in that with me and so we
we keep each other accountable there are
particular mornings where I might be
likely to skip because I'm tired and and
vice versa we keep each other
accountable in that and it's a really
nice thing so
I think that covers the long list of
things I wanted to mention about uh
various strategies to support your goals
to set better goals to increase your
likelihood of attaining goals uh I did
if you would allow me
have a brief pitch I I want to add yeah
either one or two things first I have
two things in mind but after I say the
first one we'll see if I remember the
second one sure anyway that's a habit I
got out of I I used to on podcasts say I
have four thoughts related to that and
then I would finish the third and be
like [ __ ] yeah well I can't think of it
I I've already uh pre-built myself an
escape hatch yeah so slack but there is
a cost because everyone's gonna think
you're an idiot yeah I mean they they do
already that's fine
um but yeah so one of the things
one of the things that I I think has
helped me out quite a bit that I've
noticed as a commonality
um for when when I'm successful with
goals versus when I fall short with
goals is uh and this this relates to
self-efficacy as well I think is
basically like how I frame failures and
setbacks like if I'm relatively
confident in my ability to accomplish a
goal I've set for myself then if I have
a setback like I don't care yeah um and
if anything I I view it as a positive
thing because I can treat it as a
learning experience like I hit this this
roadblock uh maybe I didn't foresee it
but now I know that this is something
that might get in my way and might make
it more challenging to reach my goal so
now I can learn from that and develop
new strategies either to not have as
large of a setback if I hit this
roadblock again or just to avoid that
roadblock and the future and
um
so like that's that's how I've always
approached most things in my life uh
because I think I'm just like naturally
a relatively confident person and if I
set a goal for myself I'm like like I I
frame it in my head as like well if I
wasn't going to reach this goal I
wouldn't have said it in the first place
so like it it it is an inevitability
that it will come to pass and it's just
a question of how long it will take
um but like I've always like I have
always struggled quite a bit with weight
loss and I kind of like mentally audited
myself maybe like six months back and
realized like dude I approach like
uh historically I approached weight loss
uh and and habits and behaviors around
weight loss just like completely
differently than I approach any other
sort of goal I've ever had for myself
um because like I think I did have
like such a long history of struggling
with it in such a long history of like
failing to accomplish weight loss and
failing to to keep the weight off like
once I would lose it that I think I
would go into attempts to lose weight
with a completely different mindset
where setbacks I I would interpret them
more as like
actual failures instead of just learning
opportunities
um
and I I think this time around I've been
more successful because like I I did
mentally audit that for myself and I was
like look theoretically there's no
reason I shouldn't be able to do this
like ultimately it does just kind of
come down to physics uh and so I just
need to figure out strategies that will
allow me to be successful and so I was
like still vaguely pessimistic when I
started out and that's one of the
reasons that I didn't talk about it uh
much at all until until I had like at
least a couple months of success that
felt like it would be sustainable but I
I approached it completely differently
where I was like you know regardless of
how I feel about it right now I'm going
to attempt to approach this the same way
I would approach anything else
um like I know I'm going to fall short I
know I'm going to have setbacks but like
a goal I set for myself is every single
time I have one of those I'm going to
learn something from it and like build
the skills necessary to be more
successful moving forward
um
and so I mean that that I think is
vaguely related to
a lot of the things we've talked about
thus far like you know Mastery versus
performance like am I building the
skills necessary to be successful but it
was more of just like a mental frame
more than anything
um like do like are you viewing setbacks
more as
a bad thing like categorically like I I
didn't do what I wanted to do now it's
going to take me longer to reach my goal
or are you viewing it as a positive
thing like ultimately you wish it didn't
happen but it is an opportunity to to
learn from it
um
and yeah like that that is something in
the context of weight loss that I've
always struggled with and I I think I'm
getting a lot better about it and it's
it's helped me out a lot yeah and and
from that description you can see those
those elements of like being more
process oriented focusing more on
Mastery having a flexible concept of you
know instead of having rigid you know
setback is bad success is good it's a
more flexible perspective uh that that
has some gray areas there where it's
like okay there's
um you know things are are slowing down
a little bitter we've had a little
setback that doesn't mean failure it
means it's time to adjust a little bit
you know it's time to to dig for some
kind of additional strategy yeah so um
that was that was the first thing I
wanted to say I do remember the second
thing I wanted to say hell yeah success
um anyway so
I think kind of a broad theme running
through a lot of this uh is just that
like
Good Vibes approaches to goal setting
tend to work better
um and like so one of the things that
that I personally find pretty
frustrating about just just kind of like
narratives in the broader Fitness
industry in general is there there are a
lot of like negatively framed things
like you know if if you fail at a
particular like Fitness or weight loss
related goal like you know it's because
you didn't want it bad enough like you
you didn't
um
you know like you
it's it's almost like infantilizing
almost it's like yeah look if if you're
a [ __ ] adult you should be able to
eat right and get to the gym and like if
you can't you're just a [ __ ] baby
right and like there there's a lot of
that and
I guess it makes people feel good to say
it like I I think ultimately there the
the speaker is getting far more out of
statements like that than the listener
is yeah
um like ultimately I think that's an
absolutely dog [ __ ] approach to this
type of stuff overall because like
ultimately like if that's sort of the
mental framework you're working with
there really aren't any good vibes if
you accomplish what you were trying to
because you're kind of framing is just
like well it's a matter of
responsibility and like if you do this
it's what you were supposed to do
already like that's the responsible
adult thing to do yeah and so like you
you don't get kudos for it you don't get
a little gold star for doing what you
were supposed to do and then like if you
fail or have a setback it's kind of like
infantilizing like you're you're you
don't have restraint you're being a
[ __ ] child and so like ultimately
like having high self-efficacy 10 to be
good in pretty much all aspects of life
and certainly in pursuit of like Fitness
or body comp related goals and that that
entire framing of you know how how you
approach goals and how you approach
setbacks like ultimately you're
You're Building kind of a mental schema
where if you do have a setback uh your
the way you're interpreting that is
going to be very deleterious for
self-efficacy there's a lot of Shame
yeah linked to it yeah and like
I don't know one
it's not fun like it's uh probably not
the most mentally healthy way to
approach this stuff and two like it is
it is just generally less effective
um
and I think that uh
I think that you know obviously things
that work
better or worse if her person to person
um and and it's not hard to find
examples of people who who
have just taken like kind of the White
Knuckle approach to Fitness weight loss
whatever and were quite successful with
it
um but I I think that it's easy to over
generalize those anecdotes is like I I
mean as you've been talking about this
whole time the the research tends to
suggest that uh alternate approaches in
addition to just
being associated with better Vibes do
tend to be more effective right yeah
it's um
I totally agree I I think that it is
much more uh constructive it's much more
positive it's much more effective to
take
a more evidence-based approach to what
seems to help people uh change health
related behaviors and what seems to help
people with goal attainment and uh yeah
evidence-based is not a slogan when we
want to solve a problem we should try to
consult with relevant evidence if it's
available and the evidence available
does not indicate that producing shame
and embarrassment and low self-efficacy
is correlated with really positive
behavior change yeah the research very
conclusively shows the opposite to be
true in most cases
um but yeah so if if I could make a
brief pitch
uh New Year's is coming up
and as you can tell I've been really
digging into this literature and
enjoying it
um one of the things that made me very
proud when I was doing that is our diet
app macro Factor
um I think fits in really well with a
lot of some of these
goal reinforcing Concepts and so I did
want to at least acknowledge that
because I'm proud of it it's it's an app
that was carefully and thoughtfully
designed and we want it to be a
supportive tool that helps people
um when I say we I mean mostly Corey and
Rebecca because they're the brains
behind the operation but
um I'm really proud of the way that it
is compatible with the evidence on
supporting proactive Behavior change and
goal attainment so we talked a little
bit about
being approach oriented
um rather than avoidance oriented and
just the nature of how macro Factor
functions uh there are no overly
restrictive food or macro restrictions
it's not like you go to a list of foods
and it says oh no don't eat the bad ones
eat the good ones it's not like that
it's about logging what you choose to
include it's not about fixating on what
you exclude right so it's a very it's
very approach oriented in nature and
please feel free to chime in if I'm if
there's anything that I'm omitting here
uh being process oriented one of the
things that we see with a lot of users
is they mention that they refer to the
first week or two as feeding the
algorithm and it does really get people
into the you know users get into this
uh kind of mental framework of I do my
thing I focus on the process I feed good
data to the algorithm it's it reacts and
it's this kind of back and forth it's
extremely process oriented and of course
there is goal setting that involves
endpoints but what we really focus on
with the goal setting
is the rate of change you know what we
really focus on is when we do have
deviations not over correcting but
getting back on track we focus on not
getting to this weight at this date by
any means possible but getting into the
process of getting on that trajectory
and if we get a little bit off the
trajectory it doesn't Force you back
onto that timeline of course you can
make adjustments to get there but the
whole idea is that the Gen I mean the
the way the algorithm functions is
inherently process oriented and so is
the user experience yeah the the
adjustments aren't punitive it's not
like you ate a cumulative a thousand
calories more this week than you were
supposed to and therefore we're going to
bump your calories down a thousand next
week to make up for it it's right like
you know what you didn't stick to your
goals quite the way that you intended to
and uh tomorrow's a new day you know
absolutely dust yourself off and try
again and we still will use that
information to inform what do we do what
do we need to do today to get on the
desired rate of weight gain or weight
loss or maintenance it's not about how
do we clean up this mess from yesterday
correct that's not the focus another
thing
reinforcing flexible restraint rather
than rigid restraint the way the app
functions there is no need nor is there
an ability
to distinguish between adherent or
non-adherent
it is immaterial to the way that the
algorithm functions the algorithm adapts
to what you did and does not need to
bend that into
great adherence or moderate adherence or
poor adherence it's simply not a factor
you have targets you strive for them you
will have varying levels of success day
to day but there is no concept of
non-adherence there's no concept of
day-to-day failure uh and we also as an
extension of that made a lot of design
choices not to include numbers that
become red you know if your goal was 70
grams of fat the number doesn't turn red
when you hit 71. that's not something
that happens
we don't have a bunch of scary banners
and negative alerts when you go over a
Target when cutting or if you go under a
Target when you're bulking right it's
it's a very adherent neutral approach
that doesn't just reflect the way the
algorithm functions but also the design
elements and what we're trying to do is
facilitate positive reinforcement of
flexible restraint uh Mastery promotion
um you know on the uh as you get deeper
into using the app
um you know it's in my opinion a really
rich user experience there's a lot of
analytics and functionality that the
more you use it the deeper you can dig
into some of those aspects and I have
noticed that a lot of users seem to feel
like they are learning to Leverage The
Tool more effectively the more that they
use it there's kind of a Mastery
involved with digging deeper and deeper
into the analytics and into the various
features that are available
um it also you know in the course of
using this type of app
of course you're going to be building
skills related to cooking related to
meal prep putting together meals based
on the different food ingredients you
have prepped so over time you're
learning the skills and learning to
Leverage The Tool in a way that supports
success and becomes more familiar over
time and then of course we even kind of
on a meta level reinforce this idea of
Mastery because we have this public
roadmap and so it's not just asking
users to you know dig into the features
that are available but it also
encourages a bit of reflection and says
what kind of tools would help you be
even better at mastering this process
and I think it encourages users to take
a step back and say not just what is
available to me but what types of things
are required for me to gain even more
Mastery and more uh have more tools to
utilize in this process
slack with a cost there are all sorts of
options available for variable
day-to-day intake uh you know whether
you're using a coach plan or a
collaborative plan you can have high
days and low days in terms of caloric
intake on a collaborative plan you can
set all sorts of different variable
intakes from day to day you can have a
planned hedonic deviation you know say
on Saturday I'm going to have a big
influx of calories and adjust my other
days accordingly
um you know slack with a cost is
absolutely built into the functionality
of the the app and it's it's underlying
algorithm
habit reinforcement uh we spent a lot of
time and by we I mean Corey and Rebecca
making the Food Locker the food logger
extremely efficient uh I've been blown
away with what they've been able to
accomplish in terms of making it a
really seamless efficient food logging
experience and that does facilitate for
example habit stacking you know if you
really feel like logging your food is a
frictionless event you can easily stack
when I'm preparing a meal I stack on
logging the meal you know or at one
point at the end of the day with
whatever habit I'm stacking with I go
and log my foods for the full day if you
prefer that approach and again it's a
seamless experience that makes habit
stacking more feasible if it were an
experience that was more cumbersome and
had more friction it would be a lot
harder to kind of just tack it on to an
existing thing you are going to do
um and then of course we've got the
smart history that reinforces habits
related to food select action so uh the
smart history considers not just hey
what are things you ate the last 30 days
but what do you tend to eat and when do
you tend to eat it so when you open up
the app at 10 am the app knows not just
what foods you generally like but what
foods you prefer at around 10 a.m and so
if you were thinking you know what I
might do a little bit of a high calorie
deviation you open up your app and it
says hey do you want to go with the oats
and blueberries again you say
yeah yeah I probably do and it's not
forcing you into that decision but it is
kind of reinforcing the habits that
you've already ingrained in previous
days and then of course we do have a
tile on the dashboard that talks all
about your habits with tracking it gives
different analytics related to streaks
you have going on and helps to reinforce
regular self-monitoring so keeps you
engaged with the process of regularly
logging your weight and your nutrition
data and then finally there's social
support and feedback so we do have daily
updated analytics that are personalized
within the app and that personalization
is key studies looking at feedback if
it's not personalized it just doesn't
work as well
the daily stuff is what you opt into you
can look into the dashboard and see how
things are changing day to day but the
nudge is weekly the nudge to go ahead
and do an official check-in with the
application uh and weekly I think is a
nice sweet spot based on the evidence
available that frequent enough to give
you a nice little nudge but not so
frequent that you're like dude get this
crap off the screen right yeah and then
of course the biggest part of social
support is that we do have the Facebook
group and the subreddit uh really nice
supportive communities where people can
talk about their goals how things are
going discuss strategies that they're
using discuss uh challenges that they're
facing uh and it's it's proven to be a
really nice uh really nice little
environment
I agree
all right that does it for today's
episode which was a replay of episode
71. if you've never seen or heard that
episode we certainly hope that you got a
lot of valuable information from it even
if you saw or heard episode 71 the first
time around we still hope that perhaps
you got some really helpful reminders or
even got something new uh listening a
second time so that does it for today's
episode if you want even more
information on evidence-based goal
setting we do have a stronger by science
article on the very same topic you can
check that out by going to
strongerbuyscience.com goal setting and
of course the link to that episode is in
the description or the notes for today's
episode as always thanks for joining us
and we'll see you again very very soon
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules we
hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
can sign up for the free newsletter at
strongerbuyscience.com newsletter or
just go to the stronger by science
homepage and click the free programs
button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]